jojo was geht und herzlich willkommen
zur nächsten folge minecraft war mit
dabei ist wieder luca ja genau und ich
habe mir für die heutige folge wie lu
besorgt denn damit wird die change zu
tun haben ich gehe erst mal auf dem
server und werde weiter nach diamant ost
suchen
das sind glaube ich schon wieder die
gleichen die jetzt drauf sind schon
wieder sind wieder die gleichen genau
und die change heute sieht so aus lucka
stellten wir ab und zu meine
rechenaufgabe und dann habe ich mir
bestimmt habe ich bestimmte zeit die zu
rechnen also einfach so eine kopfrechner
aufgabe hatte war nicht mein
lieblingsfach muss ich dazu sagen und
dann probiere ich habe mein glück oder
anfang der ersten auch da ja wir müssen
erst mal überlegen wie viel zeit wie
viel zeit habe ich ich würde sagen ich
mache einen countdown und für jede
aufgabe gebe ich dir ich weiß nicht ich
hab ein paar aufgaben ich besitze ich
vorbereitet aber ich mache das aus dem
kopf nach der einfachen die aufgabe wie
viele sekunden zeit hast und danach die
aufgabe
okay in ordnung also du hast fünf
sekunden zeit für diese aufgabe ok 7
millionen 300.000 durch wie hippie szene
falsche antwort hier halt die klappe
schon was ein machbares ok mag es erst
mal bekommt es jetzt viele auf den kopf
auch dann ernst man ok weiter kompletten
zombie der kriegt auch auch von dir habe
also ein spritzer hin wie du so ich
dachte für jede falsche aufgabe eine
ganze flasche wie echt gut ich sehe aus
wie sie diesen kuchen mit einer
sahnehaube also keine chance gehabt so
ein
ich hatte einen spritzer spritze ich ein
video auf dem kopf nächste aufgabe max
ja nächstes nicht so schnell
mein ganzer kopf ist doch voll mit blut
danach er die aufgabe die sie hin
ok kleine emma ist sieben jahre alt
ich hatte so oft hört man ja ok 7085 los
zehn sekunden 51
luca vielleicht sollten wir sind
geschenk für dich machen
doch es richtig den rechner eingegeben
dadurch war voll und zählen mit dem
counter und hier bin die zeit mit
begangen
wir alle haben diesen einen freund der
sagt er könnte gut rechnen 19 durch 13
sekunden sechster periode drei es
richtig dass gegen aber noch jetzt du
hast du diese nebst ging aber noch lass
dir diese nächste aufgabe drei sekunden
zeit und ich will die korrekte antwort
okay 4 durch 0 marcel ist nicht
definiert bei weitem nicht durch 0
teilen
ich bin so ein taschenrechner deshalb
gebe ich einfach materials lösung aus so
ich mache mir jetzt autobahn
ich lasse meine kleine pause uneinig
dummkopf
ich habe irgendwo mein ich habe nein ich
habe keinen crafting table hier dabei
ich bin noch so dumm wie stroh
luca wieso hast du mir nichts gesagt die
hast du kann mitgenommen luca die
aufgabe vor der magischen miesmuschel
die welt fragt sich wieso sie nie
magische miesmuscheln hast uns darüber
aufmerksam gemacht dass max den world
table vergessen hat komisch es nicht
gewesen sein so was dass ich war selbst
lukas ist leider wissen
problematischer als ich als ich dachte
ja danke danke für deine anteil haben
vielen vielen dank echt aufgabe bitte
münchen rechenaufgabe ja unbedingt komm
gib mir eine zehn sekunden zeit 27 +53
575 ja mal okay leute ich muss jetzt
darum also ohne mein ohne eine
spitzhacke und sonst was bringt mir das
gar nicht und ich acht mal acht geteilt
durch 800
ich hab ja ich habe die aufgabe
vergessen bitte 8 kamera aus 18 mal ab
durchatmen platz acht ok naja dann okay
das ist alles so verlockend vielleicht
sind überall diaz aber es bringt mir
auch wirklich machen wenn ich nicht wie
viele lebensjahre vollendete jemand der
am letzten tag des jahres 20 vor
christus geboren wurde und am ersten tag
des jahres 30 nachfrist so stark bin ich
jesus bin ich jesus luca wie soll ich zu
rechnen
ja und ich soll es einfach im kopf
ich glaube ich habe wieder zurück zur
anfangshöhe gefunden
ich weiß echt nicht wo ich den crafting
termin gelegt habe ich kleine tonkopf
ich lasse mein adler meine art die augen
schweifen ob hier irgendwo diaz sind
aber gibt mir die szene so lächerlich
aus mit diesen zwei blu klecksen auf
meinem kopf walter es ist so mega dumm
natürlich komplett sicher was ich hier
mache leute war merkt man merkt man auf
jeden fall gibt es hier denn jetzt
irgendwo endlich mal diamanten oder holz
mannschaft wäre mir auch ganz lieb
kellogg allgemeine rechner aufgabe ich
fühle mich hier unterfordert 2 millionen
dieses fragende 2002 mio ich mache drei
millionen durch 150000 in 20 sekunden
oh gott ein 1,1 richtig 12,6 roman
liebesbrand damit weiter
was mache ich hier eigentlich gerade
13,4 i oder drei aber trotzdem falsch
naja okay du hast selbst erst mal na gut
ich gebe mich kochen beruf macht wieder
auf menschen wo leute meisters seit wir
wissen will oder wenn ich euch ein
tutorial machen soll wie ihr auch so
cool aussehen könnte dann schreibt es
jetzt in die kommentare und gewinnt
einreise turnier zu luca ist es jetzt
ist es fix also wenn daran teilnehme mit
dem max kanal abonniert wurde die
kommentare schreibt er steckt genau und
ich bin am arsch okay ich bin auf 55
also jetzt kein scheiß halten
ich bin wirklich am arsch weil ich habe
keine spitzhacke mehr und ich muss mich
jetzt mit der hand hoch bauen
ich glaube allein dafür baue ich mir mal
ne fette ladung bin weil ich verdient
habe
woher also wie so ein diadem
lass mich mal rechne luca ich will was
zu tun haben werde ich mich hochbau ist
zwar vor schwierig rechenaufgaben in
dann dazu eine passende zeit zu
überlegen
17 plus acht geteilt durch 3 in 30
sekunden
25 3 das verschlägt bis 7,8 gott nicht
weiß es nicht packt ja du hast auch fall
sprechen von nur darf mit plus 1 rechnen
ist doch schon verstrichen 180 zwei
rechnungen wird hier raus gekommen
genau ich habe zwei punkte in mathe
abitur leute kein problem für mich ist
das sehen wir gerade aussehen mit diesem
buch kopf
foto nein auch leute wie so habe ich mir
kein holz mitgenommen es ist so dämlich
ich verliere die ganze folge deshalb
nächste aufgabe ja es ist gerade 1950 in
wievielen tagen es war ein in wie viele
stunden zweien achten dass eine
blütezeit im prolog in 10 minuten und
vier stunden ist der achte
dann sind noch 16 tage 16 mal 24 42 ja
ich gebe mir das wusste sie nicht mal
bitte über sucht ist ja nicht mal zu
schaffen
ja ich bin nicht gut in mathe luca geht
es links geht schneller mit einer chance
wieder jetzt ausliest mega dumm ich kann
schicken institut okay
das ist wahre leute bei profis so sieht
war bei uns aus textil kurz dann sagst
du mich einmal herzlich auslachen bei
disco disco
da bist du zufrieden und ich habe es
nicht gesehen och gott mal schlechter
brechen
dankeschön aber manche sachen sind auch
voll schwer ihr könnt mir gerne mal die
kommentare schreiben hättet ihr es
geschafft und könnte mir auch in die
kommentare schreiben warum ich nicht
endlich mal an die decke komme 53 kann
er jetzt endlich mal die oberfläche sein
es ist so langweilig leute es tut mir
wirklich leid aber es war einfach blöd
dass ich kein holz mitgenommen habe ja
ok apropos blöd noch eine aufgabe für
max - achtmal - 97 50 alter was ich
später finden
nein 72 72 meister wohin du kennst du
kennst die screenshot bei solchen
schnurrbart ausbildung machen
ich möchte dass du wie du in deinen mund
machst ich bin ich neben ihm nicht nein
dann mach dass du auf deiner horn wenn
du so segeln macht auf einem aber nur
ich gibt nur ein spiel ab
foto heinemann ich kenne nicht alle drei
sekunden fotos schicken
hier hilft einfach immer noch wahr ist
ja es ist halt immer noch warum aber
leute jetzt überlegt was ich gerade
mache ich baue mich gerade wo übrigens
ungeschickt einfach durch stein was weiß
ich wie viele blogger ist dass erde
ja es ist er endlich alter vielleicht
warten ist wer welche auf mich nicht
muss kämpfen vielleicht wenigstens habe
ich wieder an die oberfläche geschafft
leute ist wird wieder spannend
youtube ist online ja ich habe es gerade
eben nicht gesehen
ab dann nachgeschaut aber war nicht da
okay leute jetzt erstmal eine spitzhacke
bauen eine axt ein bisschen heute ein
ich hab ja nicht mal nix mehr da habe
ich einst xxx
ich habe ich kein sticks sticks luca
wasser ja ich glaube den an elmar schnee
fiel etwa hat max du bist immer wieder
ein ja ich habe eine perle luca das
ändert werde ja muss max diese ändert
erle wegschmeißen geh mir weg mit nein
nicht nein du magst lukas ist meine
einzige rettung die magische miesmuschel
satz gesagt ja wir machen aber nicht
mehr die magische miesmuschel challenge
junge lass mich jetzt zwar jetzt ist
jetzt nicht persönlich luca das weißt du
hoffentlich weiter junge beat jud ist
die einzige deutsche im youtube rivalen
richtig traurig eigentlich letztes mal
lässt zwar noch den er oder seine flotte
glaube ich okay du hast mich gesehen
ok ich wäre gleich wieder gekickt leute
ich nehme noch ein bisschen holz liegt
wie kann das sein
bitte team aus über lebt weiter er ist
kein ding sagt er und läuft an einem
krieg vorbei ich guck mal ob ich noch
mal meinem ein loch findet wo ich vorhin
runter gegangen bin
7 mal 3 sivas 0 geteilt ich 7 x 3
geht nicht falsch ist 08 recht okay
dafür nochmal ein fettes viele freunde
und damit verabschiede ich mich von der
behinderten ware folge aller zeiten und
wir sehen zwar nicht neu